بعد جدل الوصايا الذي اثاره مسلسل منى زكي
اثارت جريمه جريمه في محافظه الشرقيه جدلا
حول حق الام في الحضانه التلقائيه
لابنائها بعد الطلاق هذه الجريمه التي هزت
الشارع المصري بسبب تفاصيلها المروعه وهي
لام قتلت ابنها
بالخمس اعوام طبعا قانونيون طالبوا بان
تكون الحضانه
واصلح لها من شتى النواحي واهمها الصحيه
الصحه العقليه والنفسيه شددوا على ضروره
ايضا الخضوع لفحص نفسي لكن ما اثار هذه
النقاشات والمطالبات هو تكرار جرائم
ممثله سواء في مصر او حتى في دول اخرى
خلال السنوات
الماضيه نتابع ونعود
نفتح هذا النقاش في فقره مع وضد نذهب الان
مشاهدينا لمصر ندح حجازي ستحكي لنا هذه
القصه
جرائم ضد الاطفال صدمت المجتمع المصري
والجاني اخر من تتوقعه هو الام
المتهمه هنا من طبقات وثقافات ومستويات
اجتماعيه مختلفه ما اثار الشكوكا في قاعده
ان الام او النساء الاصلح لحضانه الاطفال
شوفوا الاول الام دي ايه ولا الاب ده ايه
وظروفه ايه ونفسيته ازاي وبعد على الاساس
ده بيكرره لكن للام تلقائي كده
لاقي يا فرحتنا هتروح للاب في الاب فاسد
ايه اللي انا استفدته
الاسباب اختلفت في الجرائم التي شهدتها
السنوات الماضيه اهمها ارضاء العشيق او
زوجي الجديد وهي جرائم وعزاها البعض لوجود
خلل نفسي وعقلي لدى تلك النساء اخر
القضايا كانت مع اليوتيوبر هبه السيد
المعروفه بام زياد التي تم القبض عليها
وحبسها بعدما نشرت مقطع فيديو تروي فيه
تفاصيل مشاهدتها لاطفالها وهم يمارسون
افعالا فاضحه وتواجه تهمه استغلال اطفالها
للمصالح الشخصيه او التجاريه في يناير من
عام 2022
قامت سيده مطلقه وعشقها بقتل طفلتها
لارضاء العشيق الذي طلب التخلص منها بسبب
بكائها المتكرر تعمل بحث في الاسره شوف
انهي الطرف الافضل لحضانات هتبقى معاه
المفروض الحضانه تروح للام مباشره لان دي
طبيعه الاشياء الام هي اكثر حنانا واكثر
عطفا على الصغير سبتمبر الماضي حاله
النيابه العامه في القليوبيه سيده
للمحاكمه امام الجنايات بتهمه قتل طفلتها
والشروع في قتل بقيه اطفالها ثلاثه
بمساعده عشيقها لاجبار زوجها على تطليقها
قضايا دفعت بمطالبه بعض الخبراء
القانونيين بضروره تعديل حق الحضانه
التلقائيه للام بعد الطلاق والمنصوص عليه
بالقانون الحالي في حاله الطلاق لصباح
العربيه ندى حجازي القاهره
[موسيقى]
تعرفي عادل يعني فعلا هو شيء مقلق وفي
ازدياد بموضوع يعني سوق المعامله مع
الاطفال ولكن مش عارفه اذا فعلا الموضوع
يستدعي اعاده النظر في قانون علشان يعني
احداث فرديه اكثر منه ظاهره المجتمعيه
حادثه فرديه يجب ان لا تعمم البعض الاخر
يقول بانه دائما الام هي الاخضر على انه
تلبي احتياجات ابنائها طالما في السن في
السن اللي اللي لم يعتمدوا على ذاتهم فقط
لكن اليوم هذه الحادثه ليست في في مصر
ربما هي ايضا في بعض البلدان تتكرر ولكن
هل اصبحت ظاهره عامه ولا حادث حالات فرديه
كمان مش بالضروره يكون من الام يعني هو
ربما الاستثنائي يكون من الام بس على كل
حال خلينا المجتمع اختلف الشخصيات اختلفت
في اليوم
ربما
للاسف البعض يرى من انه الانتقام من الطرف
الاخر ياتي عبر عبر الابناء للاسف للاسف
الشديد سواء كان حتى بحرمانهم من المصروف
بعد الطلاق لانه هن مع حضانه الام او او
حتى اه طبعا
الاطفال بكل الحالات يعني طيب نعود الى
موضوع الحضانه
والجدل الدائر حولها معنى من القاهره
المحاميه ايمان علي وكذلك معنا من القاهره
المحامي محمد طاهر اهلا بكما ليبدا اولا
مع استاذه ايمان اليوم
لماذا
تغيير هذا القانون وهذا
التشريع اصبح مثار جدل في الشارع المصري
وحتى يمكن في العالم العربي ايضا البعض
يراه مطلبا لبعض الاخر يراه
شيء لا يجب المساس فيه
اولا السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
مبدئيا كده كان حصل في اليومين اللي فاتوا
ظاهره فرديه من نوعها على هذا الاساس بدا
المجتمع يتكلم فيها طيب احنا دلوقتي
القانون المصري ينظم الاجراءات التقاضي
بالنسبه لمسائل الاحوال الشخصيه في قانون
رقم واحد لسنه 2000 دلوقتي الناس لما جت
تتكلم اعترضت بسبب الحادثه الاخيره اللي
هي ظهرت وهي تعتبر حاله فرديه بسبب الام
اللي هي
ابنها قتلته في اكلت احشائه حضرتك مع
الموضوع ولا ضده لي
لا انا ضد ان الام ازاي ان الام الحضانه
تسقط منها او ما تروحش اوتوماتيك لها لا
انا ضد التعديل مع القانون الحالي ان سن
الحدائق ليه لان الام هي الوحيده اللي
هتكون على الابن
رحيمه انسانه تقدر تعدل له تنظيمه وقته
غير الاب خالص ولو هنرجع للشريعه
الاسلاميه سيدنا ابو بكر الصديق لما سوق
اللي حصل فرقه بين عمر وزوجته وساعتها قال
له ريقها خيرا لك من شهد العسل
لما اتكلم في موضوع الام والاب فده
بالنسبه للناحيه الدينيه يعني اديني اتكلم
كده اما القانون فهو نظم العلاقه ديت وقال
ان المفروض ان الطفل تسقط عنده الحضانه
بعد سن ال 15 سنه سواء للصغير او للصغيره
للتوصل ضد التعديل حاليا يبقى هذا نتيجه
للتواصل يعني نتيجه او او استخلاص بانه
الافضل للطفل خصوصا في السنوات الاولى من
حياته ان يكون مع امه اريد ان استطلع رايي
استاذ محمد استاذ محمد انت مع تغيير او
اعاده النظر في هذا القانون وهل تستدعي
احداث فرديه تغيير القاعده نفسها هل يمكن
فقط يعني اعاده النظر او اضافه بند موضوع
الفحص الطبي النفسي بدون تغيير متن
القانون نفسه
اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم سعادتك انا
عايز اعدل القانون واحد لسنه 2000 لان انا
ضد هذا القانون ان هذا القانون سلب الرجل
المصري كل حقوقه بما فيه سعادتك حق
الحضانه مش دائما مش دائما سعادتك انها
يعني مثلا عندنا في القانون الحالي ان
الحضانه في سن الام سعادتك لسن 15 سنه مش
في كل الاحوال بتكون الست كويسه والراجل
هو اللي سيء بمعنى ادق سعادتك كل ما في
الامر مثلا حاله حادثه زي اللي احنا طبعا
بصددها الان من قتل ابنها سعادتك وثم
سلقته ثم اكلته دي طبعا اكيد في خلل استاذ
محمد انت انت انت ليه مع التعديل يعني
الاستاذه ايمان بتقول لك انه والله هذا
هذا شيء يعني القانون حدده
هتغيروا ليه عشان حد فرديه حضرتك انا مع
التعديل انا لا انا مع التعديل حضرتك لان
مش في كل الاحوال سعادتك ان الست بتكون
كويسه والراجل هو اللي السيء لا حضرتك
احيانا في امهات بترمي اولادها في الشوارع
وفي الملاجئ عشان تتزوج من اخر فكل ما في
الامر بيبقى الاب حريص سعادتك على ابناءه
اكتر من الام فمش في كل الاحوال سعادتك
بتكون الام هي سعادتك الاقرب او الاحن
لاطفالها لا انا عايز اعدل هذا القانون
باختيار ان القاضي يخير الطفل حتى لو في
سن مبكره بان هو عايز الاب او الام
بمعرفه لجنه تشكل التضامن الاجتماعي ويتم
سعادتك اختيار الاب او الامه بمعرفه
الصغير حتى لو في سن مبكره لان في السن
المبكره الطفل لا يعرف الكذب من الطبيعي
ان هيروح سعادتك اللي يحس ناحيته بالامان
[تصفيق]
لا يا فندم
مصلحه مش صغيره
ليس مدرك
هيختار بالفطره هيختار بالفحم وايضا
اسمحوا لي ما هو ممكن ايضا كمان
ايضا ليختار الام او الاب مثلا وبشكل عام
اليس الاطفال معظمهم خلينا نقول هذه هي
القاعده وما هو غير ذلك استثناء الاطفال
عاده خصوصا في سمو بكره بيكونوا متعلقين
بوالدتهم اكثر من الوالد بحكم بانه اكثر
بشوفوها اكثر والولد منشغل باعماله وكذا
عشان الحمام والرحمه والرعايه والخدمه
والتلذذ بالصبر اما الاب لديه لديه
مسئوليات غير ذلك وليس له طاقه على هذا
يعني هو مش هيقدر لان هو مكلف ان هو يخرج
ويشتغل ويجيب مصاريف مش هيبقى عنده طاقه
ان هو يدي الولد الصغير الصغير استاذ محمد
توافق استاذه ايمان على هذا الشيء انه انه
الاب لا يستطيع لا يا فندم لا اوافق لاني
سعادتك في الفتره الاخيره انتشرت في مصر
ان الامهات بتتخلص من ابنائها سواء بالقتل
او الترك في الشوارع
عشان تتزوج مره اخرى وليس تطبق على
المجتمع جميعا انا ما بتكلمش بصدد الحاله
دي فقط لا غير لكن عموما سعادتك
لو احنا هنذكر الام اللي بعد اذن معاليك
يا استاذ محمد انا اسفه على المقاطعه ولكن
عايزه اوضح برده للراي العام وللجمهور
وللمشاهد دلوقتي لما حصلت الظاهره بتاعه
الام اللي اكلت ابنها انتوا نسيتوا الاب
اللي رمى ابنه من سنتين من على الكوبري
المنصوره ما هو كان اب برده
لو هنذكر امثله
يا فندم بعد اذن حضرتك سعادتك في الفتره
الاخيره يعني انا انا اعتذر منكم انتهى
الوقت للامه كامل الاحترام مع كامل
ما راح نقدر
بالتالي نلم بهذا الموضوع بصوره لكن احنا
سلطنا الضوء شكرا للمحامي محمد طاهر من
القاهره وكذلك الشكر موصول للمحاميه ايمان
علي شكرا على وجهات نظركم لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات